hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about
the three stages in language acquisition
uh picking up on a theme in my blog
now at the recent
portland oregon um
conference that i attended
on story listening stephen craftsman
gave a talk
and explained what he saw as the three
stages of language acquisition
the first stage is storytelling or story
listening that's in a classroom where
the teacher engages the learners and by
being very animated and writing things
and drawing things on a whiteboard or
blackboard
meaning is imparted
students start to
pick up some meaning in a language that
they are
being exposed to for the first time or
at any rate are beginners in so the
first stage is sort of stories
animated by a very animated teacher
trying to connect the learner to the
language
the second stage
to krashen is the reading of fiction he
believes that fiction which is against
stories fiction
is inherently i guess in his view more
interesting than non-fiction
and that in that second stage we
should be reading and typically graded
readers graded readers of um
fiction
and that then would eventually take the
the the learner to a third stage which
is
sort of um
a stage where they can read whatever
they want and really get into the
language okay that's crashing to do my
view and i of course
can't claim to be as knowledgeable as
crash and i can only refer to my own
experience to me the three stages are
first stage the language is unfamiliar
uh you can't tell where
as i said before one word ends and the
next word begins it's just noise you
don't know what the functions of the
words are nothing
you have to get yourself to some level
of familiarity with the language some
sense of how the language works
word order for example which very often
in textbooks that go to great length to
explain and which in fact we figure out
pretty quickly
uh so how does the language work the
verb comes at the end at the beginning
adjectives precede or don't or come
after the noun all of these things we
start to pick up on we start to get a
few we learn a few words
the language stops being noise but still
it's very difficult to understand even
after having read something and looked
up the words and we listen again and we
read again and we listen again and it's
still very difficult we're struggling to
get
a sort of a toehold in the language and
this can go on for three months or so
okay or call it 100 hours or 150 hours
lots of reading and listening the
occasional flipping through a grammar
book
not really remembering any of the rules
not noticing really a lot of the things
that they say there about how the
language functions because again the
grammar is explaining something that we
have no experience with
so that's phase number one the second
stage
is where we now
we don't have to listen
you know 25 30 times to the same story
we get more meaning we understand a lot
of what we hear
we have accumulated more words
maybe we have a few thousand words in
the language i'm starting to get to that
level in my arabic
but if we listen to something we haven't
been able to read we still don't
understand it we have a lot of trouble
remembering words
but we plow forward and
dealing again sort of a mixture of
content that's designed for the learner
with more challenging stuff that we can
really only understand if we're like on
my ipad and i can look up words and so
forth and then listen to it and so
you know we're starting to become
somewhat
sort of confident
confident that we are going to overcome
the language but still far from being
able to function in the language and
that's that second stage can continue
for quite a while and maybe that's
another couple hundred hours it depends
on the language obviously arabic and
chinese are going to be more of a
challenge than say spanish
and now the third stage and there i kind
of rejoin krashen the third stage is is
where we now have so many words
that we can read articles in the
newspaper and there's only going to be
let's say less than 10 new words there
so we are able to enjoy the language
uh and continue forever improving in the
language
while
reading things of interest listening to
things of interest
we have now engaged in the language so
if we look at these stages and relate
them to the european sort of common
european
framework
so the first stage is a beginner medium
stage is intermediate and i would say
that even the the final stage starts
somewhere
while we are still intermediate you know
we haven't yet once we're at b2
we're we're swimming we're
able to sort of operate in the language
we're able to speak to people we have
vocabulary we have comprehension we're
missing things and we're now in a
position to continue forever to improve
ourselves in the language so those are
what i see as the three stages most
people never get past the first stage
they never get to the to where they're
confident that they're going to learn
the language where they get this
momentum behind them and they're
starting to consume more and more
uh
reading and listening
which will eventually take them to the
third stage most people get frustrated
by their inability to kind of get a
sense of the language and part of that i
think is because there's too much
pressure on them to produce the language
and so they are frustrated that they
they're sort of continuing mistakes in
the language and of course i can't say
anything in arabic i haven't really i'm
going to start speaking in arabic i know
that i'll have a lot of trouble but it
doesn't frustrate me and i think if we
can overcome this sense of frustration
or inadequacy or concern about making
mistakes then we can move out of that
first stage
into the second stage and then just
continue and work our way towards
fluency there you are three stages in
language learning thanks for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you